The first I'm going to talk about the strategy for my solution, and then I'm going to show you the code.
Now, I said before that a bad strategy would be to start at the front
and then when we find the palindrome, try to extend it by extending onto the end.
Why is that bad?
Because just knowing that the first characters of a substring
is a palindrome doesn't tell you anything by expanding it by adding characters onto one end.
There's another way to look at it where it does work.
If we start in the middle, then we can expand
and then every time we move out we are gaining some information.
Let's say that instead of starting here we started here.
We say is c by itself a palindrome?
Well, yes, it is, because every one-character string is a palindrome.
Then instead of going only forward, we go 1 character in both directions.
Now we're looking at bcb, and say is that a palindrome?
Yes it is. Now we can go out again in both directions.
Abcba--is that a palindrome? Yes.
We keep on growing the solution out from the middle in both directions.
We keep on going as long as we can and find
the longest palindrome that's centered on one of these positions.
As soon as we find something that's not a palindrome--
let's say if instead of a here there was an x--then we can stop.
No matter how long the string is, no matter how many characters are here and here,
we know that nothing centered on the c is going to be a palindrome that's any longer than that.
We can eliminate a lot of the work.
That's the advantage of doing this.
What about the starting positions?
Well, we've got to start with every character being the center,
and then we also have to start with between every character being the center.
Maybe the longest palindrome in the string is just a two-character sequence.
If we only looked at the first one and then went out to the side we wouldn't find it.
If we start by looking in between them--in other words, start not with "b" but with the empty string--
then when we move out in both directions from the empty string then we check "bb."
That's my approach for the strategy.
If you didn't get the question right, why don't you try it again.
Try to implement this strategy before you look at my solution.
Now I'll show you what I did.
The key to this function is the grow function.
How do you grow a potential palindrome from the middle out?
Grow is going to a text, a start, and an end position,
which the end is going to be either 0 or 1 more than the start,
then we keep on going until we hit the end.
While the start is greater than 0, the start of the string, and while the end
is less than the end of the string and while they match,
while the character 1 to the left is equal to the character 1 to the right,
but we allow for one of them to be in a different case.
If that's true, then we grow by expanding the start to the left and expanding the end to the right.
We keep on doing that as long as we can and then we return the start and the end.
That's the grow function.
That'll find you the longest sequence that is centered on a particular text
with a particular start and end.
Then longestsubpalindromeslice just goes through all the possibilities.
It tries to grow for every possible start and end location.
Then we just take the maximum length out of all of those candidates
where the length of a slice is just the different between the two.